this morning the taliban say they
finally control all of afghanistan their
forces claim to have seized pangaea the
last major province not under taliban
control located just north of kabul the
apparent victory comes on top of growing
concerns over the fate of americans and
afghans who are unable to leave the
country charlie dagda is in doha qatar
where hundreds of evacuees are waiting
to leave charlie good morning
good morning to you vlad yes we're
having competing claims here in doha
today what exactly is unfolding in
panchayat valley the taliban as you said
claiming total victory the resistance
say they're still fighting the pictures
on the ground suggest it's all over
they've been holding out against the
taliban for weeks a group of resistance
fighters defending the rugged mountain
valley of panshir
after surrounding the region the taliban
intensified fighting over the weekend
and have now raised their flag in an
apparent sign of victory the resistance
group's leader ahmed masood made a plea
to the taliban that he was now open to
peace talks if the taliban stopped its
offensive when we interviewed him in may
before the taliban takeover masood said
he and his forces would fight to the
death if the situation goes toward a war
will be announced and we'll be ready i
fight for it and i'm ready to give my
life for it
amid the taliban solidifying their
control senior republican foreign
affairs committee member michael mccall
accused the group of holding americans
hostage
six airplanes with american citizens on
them as i speak
also with these interpreters and the
taliban is holding them hostage for
demands right now they we have the state
has cleared
these flights and the taliban will not
let them leave the airport
satellite photos of the airport in
mazara sharif north of kabul shows six
passenger planes on the runway among a
thousand or so people trying to leave on
those planes are dozens of american
citizens all the taliban would tell us
is they're looking into it with no u.s
presence on the ground in afghanistan
it's now all in taliban hands
now the taliban say they're getting
ready to announce their new government
soon but they've been saying that for
days now as far as elections in their
words that's not insight for now uh
secretary of state anthony blinken is
due to arrive here in doha this country
has been critical in the evacuation of
tens of thousands of people from
afghanistan dana charlie dagetta and
qatar thank you charlie